CALLED THE CRITICISM, QUOTE,
INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS.
>> THESE ATTACKS THAT WE'VE BEEN
SEEING ARE DANGEROUS ON DR.
FAUCI AND OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AS WELL.
THEY ARE DISGUSTING AND DIVORCED
FROM REALITY.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO CALL
THAT OUT AND BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
AGAIN, THESE ARE DANGEROUS THESE
ATTACKS THAT WE'RE SEEING.
>> HANNITY: HERE WITH MORE ON
ALL OF THIS IS ARI FLEISCHER,
AND OUTKICK FOUNDER CLAY TRAVIS.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
ARI, LET ME BEGIN WITH YOU, TOP
LINE TAKEAWAY, THIS IS TWITTER
FILE NO. IS THAT TWITTER
EMPLOYEES EFFECTIVELY APPOINTED
THEMSELVES THE ELECTION POLICE
AHEAD OF VOTING IN 2020.
NOW, PUT THAT TOGETHER WE LON
MUSK'S COMMENTS IF YOU SUPPRESS
DISSENTING VOICES THAT'S
ELECTION INTERFERENCE OR
COMMENTS THAT TWITTER WAS ACTING
AS THE PROPAGANDA ARM OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THAT THE
MEDIA DOESN'T WANT TO COVER THE
STORY BECAUSE THEY'RE COMPLICIT
IN LYING TO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
THEY GAVE THE BIGGEST IN KIND
CONTRIBUTION ONE COULD EVER GIVE
TO ANY CAMPAIGN, IS THAT WRONG?
HOW DO YOU PUT A VALUE ON IT?
>> NO, SEAN, I THINK YOU NAILED
IT.
THE PROBLEM IS CANCEL CULTURE IS
REAL.
I WONDER IF IT EXISTS IN OTHER
OUTLETS, THEY BANNED OR BLOCKED
EMAIL ACCOUNTS SO WHEN THEY SENT
EMAIL FUNDRAISERS, MANY CAME
BACK REJECTED OR BOUNCED.
A REAL PROBLEM IN THE SOCIAL
MEDIA AND MAIN STREAM MEDIA.
WHAT I WANT TO KNOW MORE OF NOW
AS THESE THINGS COME OUT IS WHAT
ROLE DID THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE
PLAY PREELON MUSK IN TRYING TO
SEEK INFLUENCE AT TWITTER TO
SILENCE OR SHADOW BAN THEIR
CRITICS, INCLUDING THOSE WHO
CRITICIZED THEIR COVID POLICIES.
WHAT ROLE DID THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT PLAY?
BECAUSE WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AT THE WHITE HOUSE OR
THE FBI OR ANY OTHER AGENCY
ASKED SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO
LIMIT SPEECH THAT IS A FIRST
AMENDMENT ISSUE.
WHAT DID THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DO PREMUSK?
>> CLAY, IF YOU LOOK DEEPER INTO
THIS, THE FBI AGENT ORGANIZING
ALL OF THE WEEKLY MEETINGS WITH
BIG TECH IS A GUY BY THE NAME OF
ELVIS CHAN WHO HAD A
POSTGRADUATE THESIS CLAIMING
THAT RUSSIA INTERFERED IN THE
2016 ELECTION TO HELP FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW HE'S ORGANIZING WEEKLY
MEETINGS WITH EVERY BIG TECH
COMPANY.
EVERY BIG TECH COMPANY WENT
ALONG WITH WHAT THE FBI WAS
RECOMMENDING BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT WE DON'T WANT TO BE
DISSEMINATING FALSE INFORMATION.
BUT THE REALITY IS THE FBI HAD
THE LAPTOP SINCE DECEMBER, 2019.
THEY HAD PLENTY OF TIME TO VET
THAT LAPTOP AND FIND OUT IF IT'S
AUTHENTIC OR NOT.
MY GUESS IS THEY DID BUT THEY
DIDN'T WANT THE STORY BEING
PUBLIC, KNOWING THAT IT WOULD
LIKELY GREATLY IMPACT THE 2020
ELECTION.
DID THE FBI PUT THEIR THUMB ON
THE SCALE TO HELP JOE BIDEN?
>> 100%, THEY DID, SEAN.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST STORY HERE.
SO FAR, THEY HAVEN'T GOTTEN
ANYTHING FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAD THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN, WE
HAD ALL OF THE CLEAR BIAS THAT
EXISTED INSIDE OF TWITTER, AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THIS, SCENE.
WHEN YOU DO THIS TWITTER FILE,
YOU KNOW LEFT WINGERS IN
GENERAL.
THEY'RE OBSESSED WITH THE IDEA
OF DIVERSITY BUT NOT DIVERSITY
OF THOUGHT.
PRONG SEVEN OF TODAY'S
REVELATION, ONE OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AT TWITTER SAID SHE
WAS CHINESE AND SHE WAS TROUBLED
BY THE IDEA OF CENSORING
LEADERS.
IF YOU READ THEM TODAY.
TO  TO THEIR CREDIT, MACRON IN
FRANCE AND ANGELA MERKEL IN
GERMANY, THEY SAID IT WAS WRONG.
OUR GOVERNMENT COLLUDED WITH BIG
TECH AND BIG MEDIA.
IS IT A COINCIDENCE?
YOU KNOW WHO'S NOT TALKING ABOUT
IT?
ABC, NBC, THE CBS, "THE
WASHINGTON POST," "THE NEW YORK
TIMES."
THEY'RE NOT COVERING THIS.
EVERYTHING INSIDE OF TWITTER WAS
IN ADDITION TO BIG TECH, A
TRI-UP VERSE RANT OF CONCLUSION,
THE BIG TECH, BIG MEDIA, THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND
CAMPAIGN ALL IN A RIG EFFECT
DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS NOT ELECTED .2020.
THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE AT ALL.
THEY HAD THE LAPTOP.
THE 51 SECURITY OFFICIALS WHO
ALLOWED THEIR NAMES TO BE USED
ON A LIE, THIS IS ALL PART AND
PARCEL OF A CALAMITOUS CAMPAIGN
HERE, THE BIGGEST ISSUE.
THIS MAKES WATERGATE SEEM LIKE
JAYWALKING, SEAN, TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS NO ELECTION OF DONALD
TRUMP IN 2020.
GOD BLESS ELON MUSK FOR SPENDING
$44 BILLION.
ARI IS RIGHT ABOUT THIS, SEAN.
IF IT WEREN'T FOR THAT $44
BILLION.
WE KNOW IT'S GOING ON AT
FACEBOOK AND INSTAGRAM AND
YOUTUBE AND GOOGLE AND CERTAIN
TIKTOK AS WELL.
IF ELON MUSK HASN'T SPENT THAT
$44 BILLION, NONE OF THESE
DOCUMENTS, NONE OF THE EMAILS
PROVING THE CONCLUSION OR THE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BEHAVIOR WOULD
HAVE COME OUT.
THAT'S WHAT HE SPENT THIS MONEY
FOR TO ALLOW US TO KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES AT
TWITTER.
>> HANNITY: WE'LL GIVE YOU THE
LAST WORD.
I DON'T SEE ANY OF THEM BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE, DO YOU?
>> NO, THE ACCOUNTABILITY HAS TO
COME FROM THE PUBLIC.
THE WAY TO DO THAT IS ELECT
REPUBLICANS EVERYWHERE AND SHOW
THESE PEOPLE WE ARE ABLE TO GO
AROUND THEM.
THIS IS THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE.
IF YOU RUN A PRIVATE SECTOR
COMPANY, YOU CAN RUN IT HOW YOU
WANT TO, YOU CAN RUN IT AS A
PARTISAN ENTERPRISE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE GOTTEN GOOD
AT RUNNING PRIVATE SECTOR
ENTERPRISES TO BENEFIT THEIR
CANDIDATES.
THEY ARE HAPPY TO PUT THEIR
THUMB ON THE SCALE.
CONSERVATIVES AND REPUBLICANS
DON'T LIKE TO DO THAT.
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE EXCELLED AT IS
CANCELLING REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE
THE PRESENCE OF MIND TO THINK
FREELY AND INDEPENDENTLY.
DEMOCRATS ARE MUCH BETTER AT THE
ACTIVISM BUSINESS THAN
REPUBLICANS ARE.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO GET BETTER
AT THE ELECTION BUSINESS.
THEY HAVE TO TURN IT AROUND.
>> HANNITY: THEY'VE GOT TO GET
BETTER AT THE BALLOT BUSINESS
TOO.
DEMOCRATS DON'T KISS BABIES,
THEY DON'T DO MEDIA.